according to Lanny Davis former Special
Counsel to President Clinton and
longtime Democratic consultant Barack
Obama will be considered one of
history's great presidents what makes
Obama so spectacular
well according to Davis to be a great
president requires a combination of four
factors first unique circumstances
making a major impact on the nation's
history like Washington and Jefferson as
framers and setting important precedents
for the presidency for future
generations second successfully
addressing one or more major national
crises Lincoln with the Civil War or FDR
with World War two third having
significant positive impacts on economic
and social changes learn foreign policy
and fourth enhancing the powers and
effectiveness of the presidency and the
future of their political parties Davis
then goes ahead and ranks his top tier
presidents he says those are Washington
Jefferson Jackson Lincoln Teddy and FDR
and he lists his second-tier presidents
Monroe Pope McKinley Wilson Truman
Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson Reagan
Clinton so where does Obama stack up in
all of this according to Davis quote
there is little doubt that future
historians will rank him high in this
second tier what were Obama's
accomplishments Obamacare well digging
the country out of an economic Great
Recession and his election is the first
black president that's the whole thing
and that's pretty weak so here's where
Obama actually stacks up on these four
factors first unique circumstances Obama
did faces severe economic downturn when
he assumed office that is not that rare
in American history according to 24/7
Wall Street comm America has had either
depressions or recessions in 1797 under
Adams 1807 hundred Jefferson 1815 to
1821 under Madison and Monroe 1837 under
Van Buren 1857 hundred pecan in 1870 300
grand 1893 hundred Cleveland 1907
hundred Teddy 19 20 and 21 under under
Harding the Great Depression under
Hoover an FDR 1973 under Nixon and the
Carter years and early Reagan years
which leaves aside the stock market
crashes under Reagan the mild economic
downturn under George HW Bush and the
bursting of the internet bubble under
Bill Clinton so the question isn't did
he actually experience a downturn it's
what he did with that he proceeded to
lead Obama did one of the worst
recoveries in American history second
successfully addressing one or more
national crises this is the second
criteria Davis gives Obama credit for
addressing the Great Recession although
his recovery was tepid at best actually
the worst since the Great Depression
average annual growth has been the
weakest since 1949 at just 2.1 percent
growth Priya
the expansion has been long but it's
been seriously underproductive under on
foreign policy Obama has exacerbated
national crises surrounding terror
presided over a massive increase in the
number of terror attacks on American
soil
he's also presided over the collapse of
race relations in the United States when
he took office two out of three
Americans thought race relations were
good he leaves office with nearly two
and three Americans thinking precisely
the reverse third a good president has
significant impacts on domestic or
foreign policy Obama's biggest domestic
policy achievement Obamacare has
increased costs and premiums thrown
Americans off their preferred insurance
plans and separated them from their
doctors all about overburdening medical
care providers and placing insurance
companies under the financial gun it
will be repealed as soon as Obama is
gone his immigration policy has left
millions of illegal immigrants adrift
his foreign policy has been a series of
appeasement and blunders resulting in
the rise of Isis a genocide in Syria the
unilateral surrender of Arachne
incompetent prosecution of the war in
Afghanistan the regional empowerment and
global legitimization of the Iranian
terror regime the creation of a
dictatorship in Turkey the empowerment
to visit skater ship in Russia the
expansion of Chinese power he's weakened
American allies all around the globe
fourth fourth factor enhancing the
future of the presidency and his
political party the presidency is more
powerful now than it was under Obama's
predecessors but that's not a
particularly good measure of greatness
since he'll be handing over that power
to Donald Trump and Obama has devastated
his political party he's lost nearly a
thousand seats across the country for
his party his party controls just 18
governorships he's lost the Senate he's
lost the house he's lost the White House
the Democrats are in the weakest
position they've occupied since 1920 on
the state level and know Barack Obama
doesn't just get extra credit cause he's
black so where does Obama stack up
historically it's actually kind of rare
that historians ranked two-term
presidents among the nation's worst the
only two-term president often include in
that list is W and that's largely due to
the economic collapse of 2007-2008 if
not for that he'd probably be somewhere
in the middle
in all likelihood Obama will rank
slightly above Jimmy Carter but below
Richard Nixon historians will probably
place him above George W but well below
Bill Clinton or even LBJ he'll rank is a
rotten president not the worst ever but
certainly not among the best which is
fitting in the end Obama was kind of
forgettable
he was a forgettable president
domestically he was a disastrous term
he's a disastrous president in terms of
foreign policy his
he's not gonna treat him kindly he'll
fade into obscurity rather than growing
into historical prominence which
actually is probably his worst nightmare
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show so many feelings uh Obama is
finally leaving Donald Trump is becoming
president so much confusion so much
chaos so much excitement so much to talk
about but first we have to thank our
sponsor winks so if all of this makes
you want to drink if you just look at
the world if you think boy I could use a
nice glass of wine either you're really
happy about what's going on and really
upset or really confused well wink can
make that happen for you with the best
wine available on the market the
wonderful thing about wink is what they
do go to their their website over at
wink comments winc try wink calm try
winc calm slash Ben and what's great
about them is that you go there and if
you don't know anything about wine you
can type in they have a little survey of
kind of what tastes you like what foods
you like and then it recommends a wine
to you the wines are cheap the lines are
really really good everybody in the
office has tried them which is why the
production quality has suffered on days
we have wine tastings here at the office
because they all get drunk and they're
more useless than usual but winked calm
brings it to you and again if you don't
know what bottled wine bring to a party
or you're just looking for a bottle of
wine with your dinner and you don't know
anything about wine and you're looking
for a solid wine at a really great price
then try winked calm is where you need
to go try wink calm they have 100%
satisfaction guarantee so if you don't
like the bottle they send you they will
replace it with a bottle you love no
questions asked and of course you don't
just get sent random bottles it's a
personalized wine membership that
recommends wine specifically for you
based on the results of your palate
profile so go to try winked calm slash
Ben right now you get $20 off if you use
the slash men and they will even cover
the shipping so you get fine wine
personalized to you at try wink comm
slash Ben and if you're ready to
celebrate the inauguration or you're
ready to lament the inauguration or
you're ready to just drink try winked
come / Ben is the place to go a great
company winc calm try wink calm / Ben
okay so there as I say lots of feelings
first just joy that Barack Obama's
leaving like that is a wonderful
wonderful thing Barack Obama has been
a barnacle on the ass of the United
States for eight years he's been awful
he's been just an abscess in terms of
politics for the entirety of his term
and it is great to see him leave I am
very very happy about that we'll go
through his final press conference and
savor every last minute of angst and and
upset that had that Barack Obama pin
leverage first I do have to note Donald
Trump today he's headed to Washington DC
to prepare for the inauguration which
happens tomorrow this time tomorrow if
you're listening right now by this time
tomorrow Donald Trump will be not
president-elect you'll be President of
the United States and there's pictures
of him getting off the military jet with
Melania and saluting the troops which is
nice because that you feel like he
actually likes the troops as opposed to
the president we currently have in
office I will say this if you're
watching Donald Trump the guy from The
Apprentice become President of the
United States and you don't feel at
least a little bit of trepidation about
that it's because you're not watching
closely enough I'm going to talk a
little bit later about what we can
expect from Trump and what our hopes
should be and what we should actually
look for from Donald Trump I will just
say this in summary here is how I'm
feeling about Donald Trump taking office
tomorrow in one yeah that's that's
pretty much it I think we can be as I
like say optimistically skeptical we
should we should be skeptical of
everything we listen I've been very
skeptical I was skeptical of Bush and
very I was very skeptical of Obama I'm
be skeptical of Trump I'm skeptical of
all politicians because politicians are
in the business of lying to you for
money that's what they do for a living
so if you trust Donald Trump let me just
recommend to you that Donald Trump is
again a politician he shifted his
positions a lot holds his feet to the
fire but we'll get to that in just a
second first we have to celebrate
because it's a day of celebration today
is Barack Obama's final day in office
yeah whoa
very very exciting stuff Barack Obama
has been disastrous President of the
United States
what's amazing is watching as Democrats
struggle with the CNN ran a story
desperately hoping that Donald Trump
would actually be assassinated really
because they hope that if you were
assassinated in the rest of the cabinet
that Trump has picked more assassin and
they haven't actually been voted on yet
so there's nobody in the cabinet yet if
you assassinate Trump and you
assassinate pence then right now as a
goes Barack Obama remains he's still the
president today so if he killed Trump
and pens today this is seriously what
CNN reported here is what the CNN report
looked like and while officials stressed
there's no specific credible threat to
this inauguration tonight due to a quirk
in America's rules for succession
questions remain about just who would be
in charge if an attack hit the incoming
president vice president and
congressional leaders just as the
transfer of power is underway here you
have a very confusing line of succession
according to the Constitution if the
President and Vice President are killed
or incapacitated next in line is the
House Speaker then the president pro
tempore of the Senate but what if
something happened to them at the
inauguration too after that it goes down
the list of cabinet secretaries starting
with Secretary of State on the day of
the inauguration as a precaution a
cabinet secretary called the designated
presidential successor will not attend
the inauguration ready to step in if
something happens but it won't be a
Trump cabinet secretary since none of
them have been confirmed yet it will be
an Obama appointees if do so of Obama
and Biden were killed and then if Trump
and pence were killed before then they
would have to happen before the
inauguration right if they're basically
saying well you know what could happen
theoretically what if Trump and pence
died and Obama and Biden died John Kerry
would become president I mean this is
like this is insanity so they're now
they're now living in this crazy fantasy
world and let's face it okay everyone's
in some sort of bizarre fever dream here
because there was a story today that
Donald Trump at the inauguration might
dance with Caitlyn Jenner okay I'm just
gonna say I don't know what the hell is
going on I don't know what's happening
if that actually happens well I guess
that'll be kind of a fitting capstone to
2016 when nothing made any sense and
we're pretty much living inside God's
burp right now but uh but let's just
focus for a second instead of getting
into the Trump stuff which is a lot of
fun let's focus on something else fun
which is Barack Obama leading so Obama
is preparing to get out good don't let
the door hit you on the way out and he
gives this press conference yesterday
and the final presser is just the press
licking him I mean it's just the press
doing its best to give him that final
send-off he's been waiting for given
that happy ending so here is Barack
Obama dealing with the press and
spilling his usual nonsense
that he's talking about how Republicans
are undermining the legitimacy of the
Republic with their concerns over voter
fraud here's what Obama had to say about
that we are the only country in the
advanced world that makes it harder to
vote rather than Issa and that dates
back there's a there's an ugly history
to that that we should not be shy about
talking about yes I'm time my voting
rights that hey the reason that we are
the only country among advanced
democracies that makes it harder to vote
President Obama on his way out he's
still rife until riffing on Jim Crow
which ended in the 1960s and in talking
about how voting rights are being
impinge he still cannot name a single
instance in which a black person has
been turned away from the polls
illegitimately he still can't name a
single instance of that across the
country so while the Left claims that
voter fraud has never happened and will
never happen without any evidence they
also claim that that there's an attempt
a market attempt to get black people to
stop voting which again has no evidence
to support it but he's not done there
Barack Obama is asked specifically about
Julian Assange because yesterday he
released Chelsea Manning the the
WikiLeaks traitor and so he's asked
about Julian Assange and here was
Obama's answer about Assange I don't pay
a lot of attention to mr. Assange as
tweets so that's wasn't a consideration
in this instance and I refer you to the
Justice Department for any criminal
investigations indictments extradition
issues that may come up in paying
attention to misogynist tweets except
for the fact that he thinks that
WikiLeaks affected the election and
Julian Assange is the head of WikiLeaks
so there's that as well
Obama also couldn't leave without
riffing on race and talking about how
America's racially divided it's more
racially divided than when he took
office because he blew his opportunity
as the first black president to bring
everybody together instead using race
baiting as a political tool and tactic
here's Barack Obama on race relations as
he leaves and and by the way it's no
longer a black and white issue alone he
had Hispanic folks oh you got Asian folk
this is not just you know that the same
old battles no we got this this stew
that's bubbling up of people from
everywhere got a stew
lots of people it's not very tasty this
stool because I'm not gonna be there to
spice up the stew again he's now trying
to make race relations more complicated
on his way out just as he has during his
administration he also defended his
commutation of Chelsea Manning's prison
sentence his decision to free the the
person who was responsible for leaking
hundreds of thousands of classified
documents to Wikileaks which resulted in
the endangerment of Americans American
soldiers and American allies
here's Obama defending that yesterday
first of all let's be clear Chelsea
Manning has served a tough prison sense
so the notion that
the average person who was thinking
about disclosing vital classified
information would think that it goes
unpunished I don't think would get that
impression from the sentence that
Chelsea Manning has served it has been
my view that given she went to trial
that due process was carried out that
she took responsibility for her crime
that the that she received was very
disproportionate disproportionate
relative to what other laborers had
received okay so we can stop it there
get the eff out dude and when you're
talking about Chelsea Manning having
served this really really harsh sentence
is a 35-year sentence Chelsea Manning
served seven to eight years and was
given hormone treatments by the federal
government because Chelsea Manning
thinks he is a woman Barak Obama then
frees Chelsea Manning and we're supposed
to believe the death doesn't send a
signal to leakers that you're basically
going to get away with it the most
laughs for the line of all of this
though was when Barack Obama starts
talking to the press because this is
just this is just if you don't spit your
coffee listening to this line it's only
because you're not drinking coffee hears
Obama you're not supposed to be sinc
offense you're supposed to be skeptics
you're supposed to ask me tough
questions you're not supposed to be
complimentary but you're supposed to
cast a critical eye on folks who hold
enormous power and make sure that we are
accountable to the people who sent us
here and you have done that and you've
done it for the most part in ways that I
could appreciate for fairness even if I
didn't always agree with your
conclusions and having you in this
building has made this place work better
it
the press has treated Obama with kid
gloves the entirety of his presidency
and the press has been very very kind
him even as he's leaving all of these
major outlets are putting out tributes
to him pitch your favorite pictures of
Barack Obama actually my favorite
picture of Barack Obama has yet to be
taken it's the one of him leaving but
but they say that they hear all the
pictures of him and his beautiful family
her all the great moments that you don't
remember from Barack Obama's presidency
here's how sad we are BuzzFeed did this
they did a whole thing about how sad
they were the Barack Obama was leaving
and then he says the press has just been
really tough on him no this is just an
excuse for him to say that the press
would be tough on Trump and they will be
tough on Trump in fact they'll be crazy
about Trump so this is a pretty nutty
story from today the Washington Post ran
a story about sonny Perdue and this
story about sonny Perdue he's the new
pick for agriculture secretary under
Trump this pit and here was the headline
in the Washington Post round so any
produces it former two-term governor of
Georgia here was the the headline from
The Washington Post quote Trump picks
former Georgia governor sonny Perdue who
once led a prayer for rain for
agriculture secretary I think it's 21
here you wanna see that headline it's
it's so the headline here is is that
here here it is this is a you can see it
right there on the bottom Trump picks
former Georgia governor sonny Perdue who
once led a prayer for rain for
agriculture secretary not two-term
Georgia governor first Georgia
Republican governor 130 years know the
guy who led a prayer for rain because
that's how much the press hates
conservatives hates Republicans hates
religious people that's how the press is
gonna treat Trump but the way that they
treated Obama was just with kid gloves
by the way it really is quite disgusting
the press does not understand why anyone
would pray for rain every major religion
has people has times when you pray for
for weather events that doesn't mean
that you're gonna get them by the way
but the left doesn't understand how
prayer works
and so they score on all of this and
that's one of the reasons why Trump is
going to be inaugurated as president
tomorrow is specifically because of all
of this so Barack Obama's leaving I
don't actually want to waste more time
talking I had all the ahead we cut a
bunch of clips and then I realized that
I'm bored with him and I'm just excited
to see him leave so he's actually he'll
be going thank God but the Democrats are
not going to be going and the Democrats
are going to continue to push forward a
narrative that really is
counterproductive Bernie Sanders I think
led this one off and then we'll and then
we'll have to break Bernie Sanders led
this one off he was questioning the Tom
Price the Health and Human Services
Secretary potential secretary listen
what Bernie Sanders has to say if this
is the new democratic tack it's no
wonder that are losing elections in
landslides across the country the United
States of America is the only major
country on Earth that does not guarantee
health care to all people as a right
Canada does it every major country in
Europe does it do you believe that
health care is a right of all Americans
whether they're rich or they're poor
should people because they are Americans
be able to go to the doctor when they
need to be able to go into a hospital
because there are Americans yes it we're
compassionate Society no we are not a
compassionate Society in terms of our
relationship to poor and working people
our record is worse than virtually any
other country on earth we have the
highest rate of childhood poverty of any
other major country on earth and half of
our seeing older workers have nothing
set aside for retirement so I don't
think compared to other countries we are
particularly compassionate but my
question is in Canada in other countries
all people have the right to get health
care do you believe we should move in
that direction if you want to talk about
other countries health care systems
there are consequences to the decisions
that they've made just as their
consequences the decision that we've
made I believe and I look forward to
working with you to make certain that
every single American has access to the
highest quality care and coverage that
is possible as access to does not mean
that they are guaranteed health care I
have access to buying a ten billion
dollar home I don't have the money to do
that and that's why the the we we
believe it's appropriate to put in place
a system that gives every person the
financial feasibility to be able to
purchase the coverage that they want for
themselves and for their families that's
really telling here is where Bernie
Sanders just lashes out no we are not a
compassionate society sure we're
compassionate enough to put me in the
Senate for a thousand terms even though
I'm 1,000 years old and completely
senile and have never done anything
useful in my entire life sure you give
me a pudding cup every so often and tell
me to stand in the closet sure you do
that but what we're not a compassionate
society okay that's
that's such utter nonsense America is by
far the most generous society on the
face of the earth Americans out donate
Britain and Canada to to one nations
like Italy in Germany 20 to 1 according
to the Almanac of American philanthropy
every single income class except those
earning less than $25,000 more than half
of the people in that income class in
the United States donate to charity
that's half of 1% that Bernie Sanders
loves to hate they give one third of all
charity given in the United States the
wealthiest 1.4 percent of Americans are
responsible for 86% of all charitable
donations made at death more Americans
give charity than vote for presidents of
the United States as far as are we a
compassionate Society America's growing
economy our blockbuster economy has made
the world rich okay we have sliced
global extreme poverty in half in the
last 25 years thanks to the American
economy we've freed people all over the
world he sacrificed American lives
hundreds of thousands of American lives
to free Japan France Norway Austria
Greece Denmark Korea Germany Poland
Hungary Bulgaria Bulgaria Kuwait Iraq
Afghanistan Germany itself Bernie
Sanders by the way he spent that time
making friends with communist in
Nicaragua right away as far as poverty
in the United States
here's Pew Research from last year on
poverty in the United States the US
stands head and shoulders above the rest
of the world more than half of Americans
were high income by the global standard
another 32 percent were upper middle
income in other words almost nine in ten
Americans had a standard of living that
was above the global middle income
standard how about the American poor are
they really hard off are they having a
hard time certainly not compared to
global standards but not even according
to basic standards of what you would
consider super poor some ninety six
percent of poor parents in the United
States report their children were never
hungry at any time in the prior year a
poor child in the United States is more
likely to have cable TV a computer a
widescreen plasma TV and Xbox or a TiVo
in their home than to be hungry poor
Americans have more living space in
their homes and the average non poor
Swede Frenchman or German according to
the Heritage Foundation and then you
heard Sanders say that our old people
they don't have savings one of the
reasons they don't have a lot of savings
is because they've social security
people don't save because they think
Social Security is their savings plan
the fact is according to Andrew Biggs
and Sylvester Schreiber in The Wall
Street Journal despite a supposedly
stingy Social Security program
an ineffective retirement savings
vehicles the average u.s. retiree has an
income equal to 92% of the average
American income handily outpacing the
Scandinavian countries 81% Germany 85%
Belgium 77% and many others and by the
way that's more money since our average
income is actually higher than the
average income in those other countries
it's also worth noting again that Social
Security eats up a huge chunk of our
budget but if this is the the play the
Democrats are going to make if this is
the way that they're gonna campaign from
here on in that Americans are stingy and
terrible it's no wonder that Donald
Trump is going to become president
tomorrow and Donald Trump should have an
easy ride of it if this is the direction
in which Democrats and the left are
going to move now we have to break here
but we have much more to discuss I want
to talk about what we can expect from
the incoming Trump administration you
know how we should treat the incoming
Trump administration plus we have the
mailbag coming as well so we'll talk
about all of that but to do that you
have to go to daily wire comm and
subscribe if you want to watch live
right now eight bucks a month we'll get
you a subscription to daily wire comm
you get an annual subscription you still
get a free signed copy of my book true
allegiance my novel true allegiance we
have some other big goodies coming out
in the very near future which I'm very
excited to announce in the next couple
of weeks and that's only for subscribers
so go to Daley wire.com you can become
part of the mailbag which means we'll
take live questions today on the mailbag
from our subscribers at daily wire.com
so go and check it out there or you can
listen to us later at iTunes or
SoundCloud and make sure the Oliva
review and subscribe at iTunes and
SoundCloud and we are the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you